[Applauso]
[Musica]
vorrei parlarvi di uno sport non molto
conosciuto ma nel quale l'italia ormai
da quasi dieci anni sta ottenendo dei
risultati eccellenti
vorrei parlarvi della mia esperienza del
deltaplano di un'avventura che mi è
successa e di come la nazionale italiana
si è arrivati ad ottenere dei risultati
così sorprendenti mio padre iniziò
volare in deltaplano quando avevo
quattro anni
era il 1975 deltaplano allora si
chiamava alla del gallo dal nome del suo
inventore era vero poco più di 11 anni
a quel tempo questo tipo di attività era
un'attività piuttosto pericolosa sia
perché mancavano gli istruttori sia
perché erano scarse le conoscenze le
parti dei costruttori e piloti ne
deltaplano si potevano considerare dei
veri pionieri che sperimentava
praticamente tutto sulla propria pelle
nonostante questo il desiderio di volare
fu uno stimolo troppo forte e in quegli
anni negli anni 75 85 e deltaplano
praticamente sul mezzo più diffuso a
livello amatoriale per volare
mia madre è sempre ci si ricorda sempre
come aveva scoperto che mio padre abbia
iniziato a volare
quando mio padre tornava a casa dal
lavoro e aveva subito mario un piccolo
infortunio non mancava di farlo subito
notare quando invece ricompariva dopo
interi week end dove non si sapeva
dov'era stato e con enormi ematomi sulle
gambe sulle braccia
lui tendeva sempre a minimizzare così
quando la notizia che mio padre aveni
stato volare divenne ufficiale tutta la
famiglia incomincio a seguirlo sui campi
di volo e appena io ebbi la possibilità
è bill and type consenso dei genitori
per fallo incominciare volare anch'io
avevo 17 anni
il testo a plano in quel periodo aveva
subito già degli enormi miglioramenti
era diventato più sicuro alle conoscenze
si erano approfondite già allora si
poteva dire che per un ragazzo della mia
età volare col deltaplano ora è più
sicuro che non sa muoversi sulle strade
con l'area pro motocicletta
ora vorrei chiedervi di fare un piccolo
sforzo di immaginazione
pensate ad un ragazzo di 17 anni
cresciuto in un piccolo paese di
montagna con la voglia di viaggiare di
esplorare nuovi territori di visitare
quanto più possibile natura che lo
circonda
nel momento in cui internet non si
conosceva ancora e i telefonini non
esistevano bene pensate a questo giovane
quale si offre la possibilità di aprire
le ali e spiccare letteralmente il volo
sorvolare montagne e laghi fiumi
visitare la natura in maniera completa
completamente nuovo sia da solo che
magari affiancato da un amico per
ritornare magari a fine giornata dopo
aver percorso decine centinaia di
chilometri oppure per perdersi in un
luogo che non ha mai visitato prima
viaggiare solo grazie all'energia del
sole e del vento
pensate ancora l'incontro con una pila
che per un breve intenso il momento
penso che questo volatile sia un
compagno di giochi bene vorrei chiedervi
non vi sembra un sogno
ebbene il deltaplano è un sogno da
vivere e rivivere e questo è stato per
me il mio sogno quello che cercato di
realizzare e naturalmente bisogna farlo
ad occhi bene aperti e ora vorrei farvi
vorrei raccontarvi una piccola
esperienza che mi è successa uno degli
avvenimenti più belli che mi porta
ancora appresso anche se sono passati
alcuni anni era decollato da una
montagna vicino a casa per compiere un
volo di andata e ritorno dopo circa una
sessantina di chilometri decido di
compiere una deviazione della rotta
classica per andare a scalare una
montagna che non avevo mai visitato
nell'appoggiare questa montagna trova
una corrente ascendente ed inizia a
salire
pochi istanti dopo sotto di me vedo
entrare nella stessa corrente ingrosso
rapace che riconosco essere quando si
porta la mia quota un'aquila giovane
bene io a questo punto mi aspetterei che
l'aquila b superi e se ne vada invece
succede una cosa straordinaria l'aquila
mantiene armi a quota incomincia a
girare attorno a me prima ci porta a
destra poi a sinistra poi mi passa sotto
poi ritorna sopra
io mi sento sotto esame non capisco cosa
stia succedendo a un certo punto avviene
una cosa incredibile
l'aquila invece che andarsene entra in
quello che noi piloti riteniamo essere
il nostro spazio vitale cioè si infila
sotto la mia la destra
io rimango elettrizzato un brivido mi
corre lungo tutto il corpo e non so cosa
fare
l'aquila nel frattempo continua ad
avvicinarsi e io istintivamente per
reazione tendo a spingere sulla barra di
controllo allontanarmi nel momento in
cui la distanza sul giudice ad un punto
tale che quasi quasi potrei toccarla
la si gira su se stessa e se ne va
mi lascia una meraviglia incredibile
mentre abbiamo già raggiunto la quota
dei dubbi e mi ci vogliono diversi
minuti prima di tornare a respirare
ebbene questa mozione che mi
accompagnava per sempre che fa parte
delle ragioni per le quali oggi volo ma
indicato anche la strada che dovevo
seguire così quando dopo l'università mi
si offriva possibilità di incominciare a
lavorare per icaro 2000 una ditta che
produce deltaplani provincia di varese
quasi subito l'occasione al volo
questo mi ha permesso tra res di volare
più assiduamente di partecipare alle
gare perché parte del mio compito è
provare delta blahnik produciamo e le
gare ma no ma no consentito di imparare
e di crescere ancora con il tempo poi il
deltaplano e le gare ma anche esperienze
come quelle dell'aquila mi hanno
insegnato che vincere una gara senza
divertirsi non ha un senso completo
secondo me dobbiamo essere consapevoli
della fortuna che abbiamo nel vivere
alcuni momenti dobbiamo saper affrontare
con spirito positivo le esperienze
uniche che che la vita ci offre il pd e
in questo modo non solo
potremmo magari ottenere anche i
risultati migliori perché se affrontiamo
le nostre prove in maniera più serena
potremmo magari ottenere risultati
migliori ma il tutto si rivelerà anche
molto più appagante
questo attraverso probabilmente anche
uno dei principali motivi per cui la
scuola di italiani e deltaplano è
riuscita negli ultimi anni a ottenere
cinque titoli di campione del mondo
consecutivi l'unica squadra ad aver mai
ottenuto un risultato di questo tipo
molte volte ci viene chiesto quale sia
il nostro segreto
ebbene noi crediamo che sia proprio
l'amicizia che si lega la capacità di
comprendere che vivere certi momenti
unici ha un valore inestimabile
queste cose ci permettono di volare in
armonia
ci hanno permesso di far diventare uno
sport di squadra
uno sport che non è di squadra come
lealtà plano uno sport di squadra e
sulla sull'armonia che regna nella
squadra ogni singolo individuo riesce a
dare il massimo di sé insomma credo che
questa sia una dimostrazione di cosa
possa la passione la determinazione ed è
un positivo spirito di squadra che
diventa infine appunto la base sulla
quale appoggiare ogni singolo individuo
naturalmente credo che questo modello è
qui concludo non valga solo per lo sport
ma sia trasferibile e dovrebbe essere
possibile trasferirlo in tutti gli
ambiti della nostra vita